so it was tough but i'm really proud of
our coaches and our players we uh
we did a lot of good things tonight but
uh you got to win these tight games and
oftentimes that's a reflection on the
head coach
john gruden throwing down the note cards
and ad-libbing
he got philosophical hell with these
note cards i'm going to say what i want
to say it's a reflection on the head
coach
that's my favorite especially um when
like someone gets busted for steroids
and they have the note cards like you
know what i'm gonna speak from the heart
i'm gonna just give it to you right
right from here folks
it's easy to say it's a reflection on
the head coach when mark davis isn't
gonna fire his best buddy the head coach
you can say that i take full
responsibility because i know i'll never
have to take full responsibility i am
good to go indefinitely as the head
coach of the las vegas raiders so
following up on that theme and again
please raiders fans we're trying to help
you here we want you to have eventually
good things we want you to have super
bowl trophies in time the raiders
actually a very long time ago were my
initial favorite team for a very
important reason i had a small raiders
helmet that had a pencil sharpener
inside of it so i liked the raiders i
don't know where i got it it just showed
up one day but that's how your influence
when you're four years old
that was a sick story mike um i knew you
were i uh
the autumn wind as a pirate is is one of
the greatest like nfl films
ever you know that intro and the song
that's the best so i i'd agree with you
there is the mystique the black mustache
uh yeah i want the readers to be good
the raiders are a team that i root for
to be good because it does feel like
there's the historical relevance and
also it just feels like everything's
more fun when the raiders are good and i
want john gruden to be good i do because
i think the nfl would be
a more fun place to a a better league
overall if john gruden's in high-stakes
playoff games i do
all right let's play this game then and
it's going to be quick and there are
three options yes no or push
is john gruden a better coach then i
want your first thought after each name
and we may get through all of them if we
can move fast enough andy reid yes no
push
no come on
all right i agree with you on that let's
stay in the division vic fangio
no i i'm a big vic fangio guy and that's
probably my bias because i watched him
coach the defense for the bears for a
few years there i vic fangio as a head
coach
jury's still out he doesn't have a
quarterback jury's still out but vic
fangio
is if he is not a head coach next year
he is the best defensive coordinator in
the nfl if john gruden's not a head
coach next year
he's on tv so i would say that vic
fangio's a better coach
okay just so we're clear you've got two
no's i'll agree with you on the first no
i say push on vic fangio anthony lynn
that
i mean it's
he's a better coach than anthony lynn
i think anthony i agree with you
yeah anthony was a nice guy two years
ago
anthony lynn's a nice guy he's got a
very talented roster and it feels like
the coach is keeping that roster from
really excelling whereas gruden
there's some roster issues on defense
which we mentioned in the first you know
segment that part of that is gruden's
fault
but he also has a i i would i would take
the chargers roster over the raiders and
the raiders have a better record so
therefore john gruden is a better coach
i think you're on to something there i
think john gruden would do tremendously
better with the chargers than he's done
with the raiders if you just swap the
players between the two teams so i'll
agree with you better coach than anthony
lynn mike frable yes no push
no not even close
frank wright yes no i agree with you
frank wright yes no push no not even
close
okay i agree with you on that one your
guy doug marone this is a dilemma for
you you're conflicted here you may have
to you may have to recuse yourself from
this one yes no push
i'll go push i'll go push and be fair i
i'll go push i think doug marone's a
really uh a good coach i think he's got
a you know there's a rebuild going on
things fell apart pretty quickly in
jacksonville
but i think doug marone i mean there's a
reason why doug maron got another year
after last year i think the the he's
well liked he's a good coach so i'll go
push
i'll say gruden's better i think
marone's biggest flaw was the failure to
really take over and assert himself when
they they brought tom coughlin in and
coughlin screwed everything up i think
at some point marone needed to tell
coughlin get the hell out of my locker
room i'm the coach of this team and
that's what's triggered this this death
spiral for the jaguars mike tomlin
i think we both can see not even close
john harbaugh no
john harbaugh no kevin stefanski
my vote right now for coach of the year
yeah oh okay uh no i i would not say
that that john gruden is better than
kevin stefanski now this is obviously
people will try to throw back in my face
john gruden won a super bowl john gruden
had a nice run in tampa we're talking
about right now who would you take as
your coach right this second i would
absolutely take kevin stefanski over
john gruden
all right and and look this can't be a
complete and total john gruden blowout
because zach taylor is coaching the
cincinnati bengals i assume you'll say
yes gruden is better than taylor
i don't
yeah but
the bengals are still kind of fighting
and they've had they've had no one they
have absolutely no one i
i put a lot of merit in a team that
doesn't give up
when they're really really bad
and
the bengals like if you look at the
bengals and and the jets or even the
jaguars throwing the jaguars like doug
marone and zach taylor their teams
haven't given up
the jets have so i'll give you that john
gruden's a better coach than him just on
resume alone
but i
i'm i've been watching that bengals team
and zach taylor and like the fact that
they're feisty with playing with just
like maybe the worst roster at this
point in the nfl that says something to
me
my biggest problem with zach taylor and
the bengals is they didn't do enough to
protect our guy joe burrow they knew or
should have known this guy plays on the
edge you've got to protect him you've
got to coach up your offensive lineman
you've got to get better offensive line
you've got to protect this guy and they
did it
i know
they had a lot of injuries on the
offensive line i think they were i think
like two weeks into the season they were
already on a four out of five offensive
linemen weren't day one starters so
in i know injuries aren't an excuse
but there were a lot of injuries on that
offensive line this year
there was also an element of nonchalance
from taylor after burro got his knee
destroyed that kind of rubbed me the
wrong way so i'm going to go yes to
gruden on that one
we're cycling now to the afc east and i
think we can make quick work of three of
the coaches bill belichick sean
mcdermott brian flores it's a no it's a
no it's a no
agreed and then adam gates john gruden
is better than adam gase
yeah way to go out on a limb there
let's go to the nfc weston one of the
reasons and
this is one tangible piece of evidence i
pointed to when i wrote up my take last
night that john gruden is being judged
by a different standard than other
coaches gruden came in and what's he
done well we need to give him time well
sean mcvay came in for a team that
hadn't had a a winning record in 13
years and he was instantly 11 and five
and then the next year he was in the
super bowl so gruden's protege shawn
mcveigh no-brainer no-brainer no brain
is the better coach
right yeah no-brainer and you're talking
about kyle shannon and for doing the nfc
west as well he came into a situation
where the
the 49ers were truly truly bad and
remember they were one in 10 and he
rattles off five wins that's a team that
didn't quit on him he kyle shanahan i've
he is one of the best coaches in the nfl
absolutely
we may have a clean sweep here in the
nfc west pete carroll
pete carroll
cliff kingsbury what do you say
what kingsbury
i'm not a cliff kingsbury believer
i don't i think he's i think he is
holding back the cardinals and kyler
murray i do i truly do
why
i just think that i i think his his play
calling is pretty unimaginative i think
kyle murray for kyler murray to
basically be that offense to work kyle
murray has to run too much and caller
murray is should run because he's good
at running but if you look at the
numbers like they don't do well when he
has to be in the pocket so i think
they're a little bit one-dimensional in
that respect
i
i think his in-game coaching hasn't been
great that um
what was the game where he tried to kick
a field goal
uh i don't even know i was so mad about
it i probably had a bet on it what was
it the dolphins game dolphins the
dolphins game yes the dolphins game
uh it was i i can't say the word i call
it chicken s football when you when you
basically are playing uh not to lose not
playing to win i get vibes of that from
him
and uh yeah i think i think the
cardinals i actually would say
the cardinals the reason why the
cardinals are kind of in the mix here is
a lot more to do with vance joseph than
it does cliff kingsbury how about that
take see
that that's a good take and now i i'm
playing my own game of is this because
he refuses to come on pardon my take or
is this some sort of a reverse
psychology aimed at getting him to come
on pardon my take if you bash it enough
he'll come on so you'll stop
usually my opinions are based on uh
losing a few bets in a row
betting on a certain coach and then and
then it's just cast in in stone until
they can reverse it with a fortune of
luck but i truly i do actually believe
this i think vance joseph has done a
great job with that defense i think
cliff kingsbury is
has a ton of talent on that offense and
they have had moments this year where
you know they correct themselves against
the giants again more advanced joseph
than cliff kingsbury if you watch that
giants game that defense was fantastic
uh and
they
they were doing kind of a john gruden
here mike they were four out of five
games and the one win they had was the
the hail mary against the bills they
were fading here down the stretch i
don't know if they'll be able to finish
it off these last three games but that
that's a fact
like you said earlier with the raiders
thinking they won the super bowl when
they played the chiefs close on sunday
night the cardinals thought they won
something when when they did the hail
murray play and they just fell off the
face of the earth for three games after
that all right i think we're gonna have
a clean sweep here in part because one
of the teams doesn't have a permanent
head coach yet nfc south sean payton
bruce aryan's matt rule
is have we hit all three on the slot
machine
i would say push with bruce arians
look i i like bruce arians
we've had him on part of my take so
here's here's showing that i am not uh
completely biased all the time
i think what bruce arians has done with
the bucks this year has been an
abomination to bringing in tom brady the
entire reason you bring in tom brady is
to let tom brady be tom brady and they
have done the exact opposite the fact
that we're sitting here in december and
we still don't really know what the
bucks are and how many times have we
heard mike do the bucks have one of the
most uh you know the best rosters in the
nfl and they have all these weapons
i i think bruce arians and listen i'm
not i'm not trying to make all these
enemies but bruce arians is the qb
whisperer right
who is he whispered with
peyton manning number one pick overall
cardinal diplomacy like you're drawing
out it's not like you're drawing out a
great performance from rich cannon
it's kind of easy to be a qb whisperer
when all your
top 10 picks
yeah
yeah and that's where i have to give
john gurdon credit i mean at one point
rich gannon was out of the nfl before he
became the guy that gruden crafted into
an mvp after gruden left for tampa bay i
i'm surprised it's a push it's a push
i'm not saying yeah it's worse i'm just
saying bruce aerians i think the bucks
are being again this similar to kind of
the cardinals the bucks are poised to go
to the playoffs i think though the
brucerians his coaching this year has
held back the box they should be better
than they should let tom brady slice and
dice teams like he always has 10 play
drives instead of taking these shots
deep and trying to be something they're
not that the best coaches in the nfl
play to the strengths of their roster
they don't try to just say well this is
my scheme and we're doing it they say
well this is your strength let me fix
what my playbook looks like to your
strengths and get the most out of it i
think john gruden does that with derek
carr i don't think bruce arians does
that with tom brady
what's driven me crazy about aryans this
year and i'll go ahead and agree with
your push
aryans has
not let brady be brady and then tried to
blame everything that's gone wrong on
brady and criticized him non-stop and
then this week aryan says i don't know
why everyone's criticizing tom brady i i
don't get it all right nfc east we got
to go quick because we're running out of
time here ron rivera yes no push
uh yes
he's better yes he's better
yeah he's better than javarius no rivera
okay so it's not oh so no so it's enough
so remember it's no yeah i'm sorry i
should have i should have better he said
it properly reveres better judge is
better mike mccarthy is a push
and then who am i forgetting
dr peterson is a push doug peterson yeah
he's also a push doug peterson
uh i'm going to say push with judge
is better than mccarthy i'm going to say
push with judge too early on judge push
with judge
better than mccarthy and no on peterson
and rivera all right last but definitely
not least the nfc north i want to work
let's make quick work of three of the
teams before we get to the last one
matt lafleur obviously john gruden's not
better agreed
yeah i'll agree begrudgingly all right
mike mike zimmer
mike zimmer's better than john gruden
okay we can skip over the lines because
they don't have a coach now here we are
we've arrived that the team that picked
up khalil mack matt nagy was coach of
the year in 2018 it hasn't worked out
well since then who's the better coach
between matt and aggie and john gruden
you know this was a this was a long
segment just to ultimately bring you to
this point who's the better coach your
coach or john gruden
well i i'm sorry to disappoint everyone
but the answer to me is a push and they
both stink that's really what it comes
down to
i i like
i i don't trust either of those coaches
to make wise decisions
um but yeah that that's really the
answer like if you told me
the bears fired matt nagy and hired john
gruder and i would be like whoa that
probably is going to be more of the same
so that tells me it's a push
yeah it's funny because when when sims
and i argued about this yesterday
because sims is a big gruden defender i
told him i think it's called stockholm
syndrome but but uh i i said
tomorrow we got to get big cat to tell
us what he thinks of gruden versus matt
nagy so this entire thing which was fun
it was all leading up to getting your
opinion on gruden versus nagi and i
agree with you it is it it it is a push
it was it was but you know what
hey but here's the thing
it highlights our point
any other
coach
doing what john gruden is doing would at
least be the subject of discussion about
whether or not he's going to get fired
when black monday rolls around in just a
couple of weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports